la particularité est de mettre à
disposition des enfants
un certain nombre de matériaux qu'ils
puissent se transformer avec les outils
qu'on met à leur disposition est de la
faute de la façon dont ils veulent en
faire ce qu'il veut et cabanes des des
chariots des suivant leur imagination
ajoutons tout de suite que ce terrain de
jeu est pratiquement le seul loisir
possible pour les 4000 enfants d'âge
scolaire qu'habite cette cité hlm de la
canardière
il n'est rien d'autre même pas un cinéma
et bien qu'elle soit presque gratuite
les activités de la maison de jeunes du
quartier sont très souvent inabordable
pour les parents dont les familles sont
aussi nombreuses que les revenus sont
modestes ce terrain d'aventuré où chacun
fait ce qu'il lui plaît a mis du temps à
être réalisés il est le fruit de deux
années de démarches et il faut le dire
il est encore un peu suspect dans un
pays où de telles réalisations sont pour
le moment l'exception alors qu'il en
existe des centaines depuis des années
en allemagne en suisse et en angleterre
en angleterre où un projet de loi
prévoit même qu'on ne pourra plus à
l'avenir construire de quartier 900
installer un pareil terrain je un
éducateur spécialisé et lin titre
permanent pour encadrer les jeunes pour
les conseiller et parfois pour abriter
les petits conflits qu'ils n'estiment
évitables cet éducateur a d'ailleurs
aidé par plusieurs bénévoles qui
l'assistant dans leurs loisirs de
vieilles planches de vieux pneus
quelques kilos de cloud il n'en faut pas
plus pour ravir les gosses qui imagina
son aidant feront d'une vieille baraque
le plus magnifique des châteaux
les réactions sont sont de deux parties
une première c'est une réaction
d'hostilité des personnes les plus âgées
dans le quartier qui sont rebutés d'une
part par l'aspect du du terrain de jeu
et d'autre part par les bruits des
bruits la présence de deux garçons plus
âgés
puisque nous touchons des enfants qui
vont de 2-6 2-6 ans 20 20 ans et puis
alors une deuxième partie de l'adulte
très alors elle très favorable au
terrain et qui viennent même soutenir
leurs enfants dans leur démarche de
création les l'avis des principaux
intéressés des enfants ils sont unanimes
pour eux le terrain d'aventuré est une
bonne chose
une preuve de l'autre côté de la rue il
ya un autre terrain de jeu où tout est
organisé sans mystère et qui ne laisse
aucune initiative aux enfants et bien ce
terrain pour aménager un grand frais est
désespérément vide et abandonnée